hey everyone Let's test your knowledge
on taking a manual blood pressure so
what I want you to do is I want you to
look at this blood pressure gauge and I
want you to listen for those systolic
and diastolic sounds
[Music]
okay so what did you get for the
patient's blood pressure did you get 110
over 70 because that is what it was now
remember whenever you're listening for
those blood pressure sounds that first
sound you hear is the systolic number
which is that top number of the blood
pressure reading and in our case it was
110 and at that point when that sound
stops it's the diastolic number that
bottom number and in this case it was
70.